a alejandro le interesa sabes la mediana
muestral es un estimador in sesgado de
la mediana poblacional así que metió
pelotas de tenis de mesa numeradas de 0
a 32 en un recipiente observa tenemos 33
pelotas de mesa y las mezcló bien notan
que la mediana de la población es 16
después tomó una muestra aleatoria de 5
pelotas y calculó la mediana muestral
así que tenemos una población de 33
pelotas y sabemos el parámetro sabemos
que la mediana de la población es 16 y
de esta población tomaremos una muestra
aleatoria de 5 pelotas por lo tanto n va
a ser igual a 5 y de estas cinco pelotas
vamos a calcular su mediana muestral y
después dicen reemplazó las pelotas y
repitió el mismo procedimiento hasta
obtener un total de 50 muestras
sus resultados se resumen en la
siguiente gráfica de puntos donde cada
punto representan la mediana de la
muestra aleatoria de las cinco pelotas
por lo tanto lo que hacen es regresar
estas 5 pelotas de tenis de mesa y
empezar de nuevo y de nuevo y de nuevo y
así hasta completar 50 extracciones y en
cada una de estas extracciones calculan
la mediana muestral y esa mediana
muestral la va a colocar en esta gráfica
de puntos sigue así hasta completar 50
muestras aleatorias por lo que cada
punto de esta gráfica representa la
estadística de la muestra que nos enseña
que por ejemplo aquí cuatro veces de
esas 50 extracciones obtuvimos una
mediana muestral de 20 otro ejemplo
por acá 5 veces de las 50 extracciones
obtuvimos una mediana muestral de
10 ahora lo que está creando con estos
puntos es esencialmente una aproximación
a una distribución muestral en este caso
de las medianas muestrales con base en
los resultados puedes concluir que la
mediana muestral es un estimador sesgado
o un estimador en sesgado de la mediana
poblacional bueno pausa el vídeo y ver
si puedes encontrar esta respuesta bien
ahora vamos a hacerlo juntos para
encontrar la respuesta pensemos en donde
tenemos el verdadero parámetro de la
población es decir la mediana
poblacional que sabemos que es 16
y está justo aquí
por lo tanto si se tratara de un
estimador sesgado de este parámetro
poblacional entonces a medida de que
obtenemos nuestra aproximación de la
distribución muestral esperamos ver una
distribución asimétrica tal vez algo más
o menos así por ejemplo si nuestra
aproximación de la distribución muestral
se vea algo así entonces podremos
concluir que estamos trabajando con un
estimador sesgado también en el otro
caso si se viera algo así ahora bien si
se trata de un estimador in sesgado de
este parámetro poblacional lo que
veremos en esta aproximación de la
distribución muestral que alejandro ha
construido es que aproximadamente la
misma proporción de los estadísticos
muestrales se encuentran de este lado de
la mediana poblacional de la mediana
real que de este otro lado aunque vemos
que esto no es tan exacto si apreciamos
que aproximadamente se cumplen
por lo tanto podemos concluir que
estamos trabajando con un estimador in
sesgado ahora si podemos decir que con
base en los resultados
la mediana muestral es un estimador in
sesgado de la mediana poblacional y
hemos acabado hasta la próxima